السنوات الاخيره لمعت اسماء كثيره من
الشباب والشابات في التمثيل ومن بينهم
اللي اثبتوا قدرتهم وموهبتهم والفنانه
الشابه ميان السيد اللي بتشارك في الموسم
الرمضاني في مسلسل الف حمد لله على
السلامه ويكون دورها في المسلسل سماح ابنه
النجمه القديره يسرا للمره الثانيه على
فكره ميان بتكون محظوظه بانها تلعب دور
بنتها
سماح في كندا
[موسيقى]
من القاهره الفنانه ميان السيد اهلا فيك
معنا ميونه وحشتيني
وحشتيني يا ساره يا جميله انت وحشتيني انا
عارفه انك انت في مكان التصوير وصار لنا
ساعه بنجري وراكي وبنحاول نخليك تفك
التلفون والله احنا يا جماعه بنصور ان شاء
الله اخر يوم فانا استاذنت بالضبط يعني
عشر دقائق عشان اطلع معاكوا
منورتنا وان شاء الله تخلصوا على خير
وتكسري طبعا الدنيا زي العاده بيحكيلي
خلاص انت صايره دائما يعني مع يسرى بتطلعي
بنتها خلاص في كذا التعاون دائم
احنا في بيننا كيمياء جميله وانا بقدرها
جدا وبحبها وبحترمها لابعد مدى فانا دايما
بتبسط معاها والمره دي حبيت ان انا اغير
واجرب الكوميدي واخد الريسك السنه دي ان
انا ابعد عن الحاجات الدراما اللي انا
بعملها
كان معنا استاذ عمر صلاح المخرج هو اللي
بيقول لنا ازاي ان احنا نقدم الادوار
بتاعتنا بالشكل ده
ومعنا العدل جروب هم الانتاج العمل ده
فانا مبسوطه معاهم قوي والكاست جميل
واللوكيشن حلو والروح جميله بين الناس
كلها الحمد لله طب اماميان شفتك نزلتي
كمان بس فيديو رد بتقولي للناس انه معليش
انا حاولت اعمل شيء مختلف السنه دي يمكن
انتم مش شايفين كوميديه بس انا حبيت اني
اعمل شيء مختلف ايش اللي وصلك قد كده نقد
اللي حسسك انه لازم تردي
بصي انا انا مش بتضايق من الانتقاد بالعكس
لانه انا لسه بتعلم ولسه بتطور وانا من
حقي ناس تقول رايها ومن حقي كمان ان انا
اخذ الراي ده وان انا اتعلم منه وابقى
احسن
فانا حسيت وانا راجع كده من اللوكيشن ان
انا عايزه اقول للناس اللي بيحبوني يعني
الناس اللي عندي اللي بيتابعوني انه لو
انا مثلا السنه دي مكانش ده احسن حاجه ليا
فان شاء الله اللي جاي هيبقى احسن واحسن
لان لسه بتعلم وحبيت كمان اني ارد على
الانتقاد اللي بيقول انه ليه بتتكلم كده
والدور ده فانتسي يعني مش حقيقي فانا حبيت
اقول لهم انه احنا بنعمل كوميدي وان انا
كنت حابه ان انا اجرب اللون ده وفي الاخر
كل حد مختلف يعني ممكن حد يتكلم عربي ممكن
حد يتكلم عربي مكسر ممكن حد يتكلم انجلش
مايعرفش يتكلم خالص فاحنا بنلعب يعني في
الاول وفي الاخر احنا نعمل كوميدي واحنا
معانا كوميديانات في التصوير وكمان في
حاجه ناس ناسيها ان انا لازم افرش يعني في
الكوميدي لازم اقول حاجه في احد يقول في
حد ثاني يقول فنضحك
فكان لازم العب واعمل دور بعيد عني شويه
يمكن انا المره الجايه محتاجه اذاكر اكتر
لان الكوميدي طلع صعب جدا يا جماعه طلع
صعب قوي
فان شاء الله هتعلموا اكتر وابقى احسن في
قريب ان شاء الله بيان انا مبهوره من
قدرتك على انه يعني زي عملتي نقد لنفسك
انت يعني تكلمتي مع نفسك بكل شفافيه
وصراحه يعني بصراحه شيء جميل يعني بس انا
شفت كمان يمكن الناقده ماجده خير الله
كاتبه كانت انك اسوء شخصيه في المسلسل
وانه انت عامله شخصيه الشخص
اللي مغترب اللي جايبه انه بطريقه فيها
تخلف عقلي وعبط قديش جرحك هذا الكلام يعني
يمكن جاتك انتقادات بس هذا حسيتيه جارح
اكيد
انا عايزه اقول لحضرتك حاجه استاذه ماجده
قبل كده مدحت فيا وقالت عليا ان انا ممثله
كويسه وممثله موهوبه فانا مش متضايقه من
الانتقاد ده زي ما قلت لك بالعكس ده انا
هتعلم منه وابقى احسن بسببه فانا مش
متضايقه منه ومش متضايقه من اي حد قال اي
حاجه على الدور ده لان انا عارفه
انت ساعات بتعملي دور حلو قوي وممكن بعد
كده تعملي دور مش احلى حاجه لك او مش لايق
عليك فانا انا متقبله جدا الاراء دي
وبالعكس انا بتعلم منها وانا بشكرها ان هي
قالت كده علشان اتعلم من النقد ده ودائما
بشوف ان النقد بناء يعني انا هبقى احسن
بسببك فانا مش متضايقه وبالعكس هي قالت
عليا كلام قبل كده حلو واكيد هتقول كلام
ان شاء الله حلو قريب
يعني يا ميان بيعكس نضج يعني صراحه كبير
بس اسمع بدي اسالك شويه اسئله سريعه في
الاخير انت الان طول الوقت ميان في قصه حب
او مخطوبه انت في قصه حب او مخطوبه يا
ميان لا انا سنجل
طيب مبروك التخرج اخيرا من الجامعه سبع
سنين
اه بس مش بسقط انا ما كنتش بروح لا انت
كنت متاكد عشان الشغل صح صح انا كان
بالنسبه لي الشغل اولويه والمذاكره
الصراحه كنت اللي هو حطها كده على جنب بس
اخر سنه قلت لا انا هحط بقى الشغل شويه
على جنب واركز في المذاكره ودلوقتي رجعت
تاني عشان اركز في الشغل اوكي التخصصك ايش
كان كان مسرح اوكي حلو يعني ماشي معه اللي
انت فيه هل حتكرري الكوميدية
هكرره بس هحسبها صح
طيب حلو مايون حبيبتي شكرا لك انا مبسوطه
جدا انك طلعتي معانا وارجع التصوير اجري
على التصوير خلصي التصوير
بالتوفيق لك يا حبيبتي يلا
قبلات من دبي الى القاهره باي باي
حبيبتي
[موسيقى]